-Guys, it is time to kick off
the first ever
"Tonight Show" film festival.
Here we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Tonight Show Film Festival."
-I'm super excited about this.
We teamed up with Samsung
to find some of the best
rising creators out there.
We got a ton of submissions
and narrowed them
down to 10 finalists
and gave each of them
a new Samsung Galaxy
S21 Ultra 5G phone.
There you go right there.
And we asked them to use it
to make a short film for us
based on the theme,
"A Different Focus."
This phone, by the way,
is unbelievable.
It's got 8K video.
That's, like, the highest
quality available on any phone.
It's got a really cool
director mode feature.
Can you just see
all those lenses
on this back?
Look at that thing.
So, the director mode,
if you do that,
you can just, like, bleep blurp
through all the different
cameras and stuff.
You could really make
a movie on this thing.
And every night this week,
we're going to air a short film
created by one of our finalists
using this phone
starting right now.
Tonight's film was created
by Pete Scalzitti,
from Rockport, Texas.
They've been hit hard
by the storms down there,
and Pete made this film
in the middle of it all.
No running water.
Everything was shut down.
His wife actually had to go
and get the props
because nothing arrived
in the mail,
and everything broke,
apparently.
But he used it and made it part
of his film, and we loved it.
That's one of the reasons
why we loved it.
So here it is, the debut of
"Moon Dog," by Pete Scalzitti.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Dog grumbling ]
[ Reverse signal beeping ]
♪♪
[ Barking ]
[ Dog growling ]
[ Sad music plays ]
♪♪
[ Inspirational music plays ]
[ Grinding ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
♪♪
[ Triumphant music plays ]
[ Dog barks ]
[ Dog grumbles ]
♪♪
-Tonight's film was created
by Shady Mawajdeh,
from Valrico, Florida.
He's always loved films
and making films,
and his hope is to inspire
others with the work he creates.
He says the film
we're about to see tonight
is about a man
who has the entire world
as his stage for one minute,
but he doesn't know what to say.
So he says everything.
Here is the debut of
"American Made,"
by Shady Mawajdeh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ladies and gentlemen,
"American Made."
[ Applause ]
[ Piano playing ]
My parents came
into this country
to make a change
with the change that they had.
I am the son of success,
so for me, it was never bad.
I'm on "Fallon," Mama.
The world is my stage.
I don't know what to say,
but it moves with or without me.
I've been dreaming of this
all my life.
I'm feeling like I'm slipping
through the cracks.
The second hand
is about to hit the minute.
This is the real game,
not the scrimmage.
So let me say this
before I hit my limit.
I am...
Arab American,
American born,
born and raised in the U.S.A.,
a child of immigrants,
immigrants who became citizens.
American made.
♪♪
-Tonight's film was created
by Margo Akopov.
She is a college student,
from Burbank, California.
When her campus shut down
because of COVID-19,
she was upset about missing
her senior year, understandably,
and having to move back home.
But she decided to focus
on the positive --
that she was safe
and she was healthy
and she was with her loved ones.
So with this film, she wants
to challenge everyone to think
of something positive
that's come from the past year.
Here's the debut of
"Over the Hills and Far Away,"
by Margo Akopov.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
[ Piano plays ]
Tonight's film was created
by Michael Hopkins,
who lives in Sedona, Arizona.
He loves movies
and stop-motion animation.
And he says if he can make you
laugh or cry or both,
then he's done his job.
The film was inspired
by growing up with his dad,
and it's about taking the time
to pay attention
to the ones you love.
Here's the debut of "Dear Dad,"
by Michael Hopkins.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Guitar plays ]
[ Keys clacking ]
♪♪
[ Telephone rings ]
[ Keys clacking ]
♪♪
[ Dog trills ]
[ Button clicks,
motor whirring ]
[ Dog barks ]
[ Birds chirping ]
♪♪
Now it's time
to show our last film.
It was created
by Whit B. Lauren.
She lives
in Southern California.
She's been creating films
ever since she was a little kid,
especially science fiction.
Obviously, we're in quarantine,
so she made
this whole film in her garage.
Super impressive.
Here is the debut of "Prophecy,"
by Whit B. Lauren.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Coughing, clock ticking ]
[ Gasps ]
♪♪
-I know you don't remember
recording this video.
Defying time
at accelerated speeds
has a way of warping your brain.
And I needed you to remember
why you were there.
Welcome to time travel.
This is how you got there,
and this is
how you're going to get back.
Now I need you to focus,
because you aren't in the past.
You're in the future.
I had a dream about something
that could happen,
and I needed to see
if it's true.
You are in the year 2026.
You need to observe,
and you need to record.
And if what I dreamt is true...
you need to come back
and warn everyone.
♪♪